merci d'être avec nous et bienvenue sur
le plateau d' europe hebdo cette semaine
nous sommes à strasbourg au parlement
européen où les députés siègent
alors cette semaine je vous propose de
faire connaissance avec des amis d'un
genre un peu particulier il s'appelle
now roméo ou encore peppers ce sont des
robots humanoïdes ils ont été développés
en partie grâce à des fonds européens
par des concepteurs français pour être
au service de personnes âgées ou encore
d'enfants autistes leurs prouesses vous
le verrez sont étonnantes
on en parle dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission mais l'actualité prime le
dossier grec est au centre des
négociations européennes tout blocs
faisant ressurgir les craintes d'une
sortie de la grèce de la zone euro
explications en images
c'est une guerre de positions entre
alexis tsipras ce premier ministre grec
et les créanciers d'athènes les
relations sont tendues
j'attends la proposition alternative de
notre homologue grec
je n'ai pas de problème personnel avec
alexis tsipras ce c'était mon ami c'est
toujours mon ami mais pour entretenir
l'amitié
il faut un minimum de règles la grèce
est au pied du mur sa dette flamber
elle atteint 180 pour cent du produit
intérieur brut et les caisses du pays
sont vides
sous la pression athènes a fait une
contre-proposition sans préciser le
contenu de ce document
le pays attend le versement d'une
nouvelle tranche d aide de 7,2 milliards
pour pouvoir payer les pensions et les
salaires de ses fonctionnaires
en échange de cet argent athènes doit
donner des gages de réforme c'est ce
qu'attendent les créanciers le fmi la
banque centrale européenne et les états
membres
mais pour le chef de syriza devenu
premier ministre pas question de baisser
le niveau des retraites ni d'augmenter
la tva sur l'électricité
c'est précisément le coeur des promesses
de campagne de sipera ce qu'ils
dénoncent un plan d'austérité
supplémentaires et prend à partie le
parlement grec et met sa fausse mais
réaliste et guess les propositions
faites par les institutions sont
clairement irréaliste elles sont un
recul d'un rapport ou une chromie que
nous avions atteint avec grande
difficulté pendant les négociations
le gouvernement grec ne peut en aucun
cas se soumettre à des propositions
aussi le compte à rebours est lancé
la grèce se retrouvera en défaut de
paiement à la fin du mois si elle ne
rembourse pas les 1,6 milliard d'euros
qu'elle doit tôt fmi un scénario qui
pourrait déclencher une réaction en
chaîne aux conséquences imprévisibles
ce scénario du grec cite inquiète les
européens et les marchés
mais faute d'entente avec ses
partenaires et créanciers la grèce
peut-elle encore rester dans la zone
euro à l'invité nous a rejoint une
invité marielle de sarnez bonjour je
vous êtes députée européenne vous êtes
élus du modem de siéger ici au groupe
alliance des démocrates et des libéraux
pour l'europe vous connaissez bien ce
dossier et les questions internationales
de manière générale une question simple
la grèce peut-elle continuer à rester
dans la zone euro si elle ne respecte
pas les règles du club
moi je souhaite évidemment que la grèce
reste dans la zone euro et je ferai tout
ce qu'on peut pour que ça se passe
on voit bien qu'il ya votre reportage le
disait très très bien il ya une espèce
de partie de bras de fer qui va devenir
stupide là il faut vraiment arrêter
d'un côté on à l'europe qui se dit ahmed
si price va céder de l'autre côté on a
chip race qui dit yvon cdcf de tout ça
est ridicule
tout ça est ridicule il va falloir je
pense que l'europe
effectivement consentent à apporter de
l'argent et à prêter à la grèce et que
la grèce concentre pas seulement des
réformes de fiscalité parce qu'au fond
ce que si prince a mis sur la table ce
qu'on dit l'aria mis sur la table c'est
pas vrai il a mis sur la table une
augmentation des impôts une augmentation
de la tva
bon pour vous c'est pas rien vous
découvrir dur ils sont à rien et
deuxièmement je pense que c'est pas
seulement là où on devrait l'attendre
d'ombré latentes sur des réformes de
structure davantage et qu'on devrait l'y
aider qu'on devrait les accompagner
elle peut pas le faire tout seul c'est
un peu les 12 travaux de ré c'est
compliqué il n'ya pas l'état grec c'est
pas du tout comme l'état français par
exemple il n'ya pas de cadastre andreck
la question de la fiscalité c'est une
grande question 1 payer avec une carte
bleue anglaise quelquefois c'est
compliqué bon et en même temps quand je
vois pas ce qu'on appelle les créanciers
on va dire quand je vois l'union
européenne où le fmi dit il faut vous
baissiez encore vos retraites enfin
hardcore justement s'il est favorable et
quand on lui dit vous lasser les recoins
d'un village anglais
oui je lui donne raison quand je lui
donne tort sur beaucoup de choses parce
que je trouve qu'il faut qu'il arrête de
jouer au chat et à la sas et aucun
moment où il faut avant sa main enfin la
retraite moyenne je crois
en grèce la retraités grecs c'est aux
environs de 630 euros faut peut-être
arrêter maintenant j'ai l'impression
qu'on demande quelquefois aux grecs des
choses que nous mêmes dans notre propre
pays jamais on demanderait à nos
compatriotes on leur demande par exemple
de remettre le départ à la retraite à 67
ans vous entendez ce genre de discours
en france non donc voilà il faut être
aussi dix jours avec les grecs
comment expliquer ce que c'est les
créanciers soient aussi parce que ils
ont peut-être un point de vue qui est
d'abord un point de vue comptable je
crois qu'il faut avoir un point de vue
qui soit un peu plus large un peu plus
large explique aussi un peu plein
politique un peu plus large
il faut au fond qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut que la grèce entame
vraiment et ça fait des années et des
années que ce battement s'attardent un
certain nombre de réformes structurelles
qui derrière lui permettront d'avoir une
croissance durable et vous essayez juste
les danses et de chants oui il faut
l'aider dans ce chemin il faut donc de
sipera ce accepte de réformer peut-être
élargissent aussi sa base électorale il
ya un parti centriste aux polémiques et
très bien peut-être qu'il faut qu'ils
acceptent de s'élargir un petit peu pour
faire les réformes et ce qu'il accepte
quand même autorité et qu'à ce moment là
bas on se montre solidaire de la grèce
ici dit j'accepte l'austérité mais il
faut que le niveau d'eau s'étaient soit
acceptable et là ça ne laissait pas moi
je pense que c'est pas la question de
l'austérité et de l'augmentation des
impôts qui règlera le problème de la
grèce s'assied de manière comptable de
penser les choses c'est la question des
réformes et ses réformes
elles n'ont que trop tardé donc faut que
tu si prince s'engage à réformer et une
base politique large pour pouvoir le
faire ça ça va être un enjeu politique
chez lui qu'il arrête de nous raconter
des histoires et en même temps qu'en
face on accepte une solidarité
intelligente et un partenariat
intelligent alors pour l'instant c'est
pas tout à fait le cas
non une question sur la dette 180 pour
cent du produit intérieur brut cc
astronomiques
je ne savais pas que le fait de monsieur
type race oui rappelons les choses quand
même c'est évidemment précédent avant de
les laver au fond trafiqué ses comptes 1
et son pourcentage de déficit qui nous
avait raconté des histoires qu'ils
avaient raconté à l'union européenne des
histoires c'est une responsabilité des
dirigeants grecs on va dire droite et
gauche confondues et de l'europe aussi
qui l'a saisie versa et danses de
l'europe
y a pas vu alors on va dire si la
résidence habilité
un collective et globale ce qui serait
bien maintenant c'est qu'ils en sortent
tous par le haut qu'ils arrêtent ce
petit jeu là comme ça vous pensez que
des moulins derrière pour lui permettre
de faire des deux ans à quatre ans pour
voir un jour qu'on mette les dossiers
sur la table
qu'on soit capable d'être solidaires
avec les grecs de les aider là dans la
passe financière qu'il traverse et que
entame enfin les réformes c'est quand
même pas si compliqué sa faute il
restructure et éventuellement la d'année
oui tous mûri se dit qu'elle veut bien
sûr à partir du moment où je pense
qu'elle rembourse 20 et sur un destin de
réformes et se met sur un chemin de
réformes et que d'ailleurs je note nous
ne faisons pas nous chez nous ainsi
volontiers que cela mais à partir du
moment où la grèce se mettrait sur un
chemin de réformes
il faut à ce moment là qu'elle puisse
compter sur nous alors l'autre dossier
marielle de sarnez qui préoccupent les
européens et vous même c'est l'ukraine
là aussi les négociations sont bloquées
l'allemagne lors du sommet du g7 a été
clair écouter ingré merkel
qu'ils adoraient nous sommes prêts à
renforcer les sanctions contre la russie
si nécessaire même si ce n'est pas ben
sont en effet que nous avons avant tout
tenter pour faire avancer le processus
de mise est ce que un grand honneur que
la raison bien sûr qui pourrait me
donner tort relançons le processus de
mix mais moi je suis quand même très
très inquiets maintenant elle dit s'il
le faut y aura des sanctions
de nouvelles oui je suis très inquiète
ou parce que j'ai pas le sentiment que
les sanctions portent vraiment leurs
fruits 1
mais je n'ai pas le sentiment que
poutine recul j'ai le sentiment que la
déstabilisation c'est le minimum comme
terme qu'on peut utiliser deux une
partie de l'ukraine et de l'est de
l'ukraine continue de plus belle on l'a
vu encore récemment que poutine jeu un
jeu est effectivement extrêmement
troublant alors il va nous dire mais
c'est les séparatistes en fait c'est
très bien que c'est lui qui est derrière
que l'ukraine est dans une mauvaise
situation économique que le conflit sur
le gaz entre l'ukraine et la russie
perdure ça fait d'ailleurs des années
que ça perdure
rien de tout ça ne va alors oui il faut
continuer à voir les sanctions et en
même temps nécessaire et en même temps
je pense qu'il faut si on peut en même
temps que les sanctions ne pas rompre
totalement dialogue
oui mais voilà ce que je comment peut-on
on va envoyer c'est elle une armée et
des soldats disons les choses comme ça
honnêtement 1 donc il faut qu'on
continue à être dur et à maintenir ces
sanctions
voilà ce que je crois que les accorde
l'apport de minsk quand même poutine s'y
était engagé et en même temps on sait
bien que la seule force des sanctions ne
suffira pas et donc je pense qu'il faut
des voies de dialogue ce que je vous dis
c'est pas très simple je vous la corde
mais je crois que c'est le seul chemin
oui c'est un peu des injonctions
contradictoires oui bien sûr mais vous
pouvez pas non plus dire ben voilà on
discute plus jamais de rien avec poutine
on sait quand même que il a une
influence par exemple en syrie on sait
qu'on a des as besoin de vue les deux
mondes amont nous avons besoin que
l'ensemble l'ensemble des grandes
puissances aille dans le même sens que
tous les ans des alizés ainsi rio est
absolument terrible donc besoin des
russes mais écoutez on a besoin de
l'ensemble des grandes puissances
et de la russie aussi et de quel droit
les états unis se met même si je suis
très critique un pardon sur poutine
sauce qui fait en russie sur même sont
ces atteintes aux libertés en russie
est ce que les états unis ont raison de
se mêler du dossier ukrainien
à votre avis ce qu'il veut les etats
unis c'est compliqué hein ils croient
toujours qu'ils sont une grande
puissance mondiale et qui peuvent
décider monde entier et en fait on voit
bien ils ne sont plus sur la scène
mondiale et il ne pèse plus la scène
mondiale donc tout ça ça reste assez
rhétorique on va dire c'est au niveau du
discours moi je pense qu'il faut
stabiliser les choses en ukraine qu il
faut que l'union européenne l ukraine à
se développer économiquement c'est
extrêmement important qu'il faut essayer
de tout faire et là angela merkel a
raison pour faire respecter les accords
de minsk et en même temps je pense au
monde tel qu'il est et là je vous redis
qu'on a besoin de tout le monde
on a besoin de tout le monde et alors
est ce qu'on va vraiment besoin des
états unis c'est une petite question
pour terminer cette partie
est ce qu'on a besoin des états unis et
de signer ce fameux traité d' échanges
transatlantiques alors pour l'instant la
discussion ici on est allé le vote a été
repoussé
est ce qu'on va dire pour ceux qui nous
regardent qu'eux y aura pas de signature
demain ni après demain mais après après
demain ça ça peut les rassurer
ce qui fait peur cette voie là ça il
faut déjà dire cette première chose
parce que c'est pas un traité au fond ce
n'est pas un accord traditionnel où on
dit on va simplement baisser les tarifs
pour les entrées des produits sains
comme on faisait d'habitude le glacé
d'un traité qui cerise et aux échanges
entre les dents des normes et donc des
normes y en a des milliers des centaines
de milliers et donc il faut essayer
d'avoir une convergence vers les normes
sont diminués en aucun cas les normes
européennes à ce qu'elles sont c'est à
nice les normes
oui mais c'est formidable qu'elle a rôdé
commun spears mais il faut le maintenir
faut le développer et si le plus
possible de monde sur la planète pouvait
bénéficier de normes les plus exigeantes
possible ce serait une bonne chose donc
ce sera pas signée demain on le donnera
du doyen en europe et pas du tout très
bien
marielle de sarnez est ce que vous
connaissez now petit robot c'est bien
c'est le petit robot qui nous
intéressait pour cette émission merci
beaucoup merci à vous d'y avoir
participé et nous on continue donc avec
ces petits robots qui sont financés en
partie par l'union européenne
l'un d'eux a été développé par une
société qui se trouve aux portes de
paris propose regardez ce reportage de
marion le faire et léna thuillier
vous venez de rencontrer now l'un des
robots humanoïdes développé par la
société aldebaran véritable compagnon et
aide à l'apprentissage
il peut par exemple vous enseigner les
tables de multiplication
c'est devenu un vecteur un support
pédagogique
d'abord dans les grandes places les
universités puis après bas jusqu'au
lycée au collège et même maintenant on
trouve deux on trouve des nao dans l'est
dans les classes dans les écoles
primaires et même dans les maternelles
et puis peppers notre dernier né bientôt
hanau et pepper bénéficieront
d'innovation développées grâce est un
projet financé par des fonds européens
sont les projets partenariaux et donc
pour être éligible il faut venir là en
disant j'ai un problème à régler j'ai un
marché à conquérir et j'ai aussi un
partenaire scientifique qui va m'aider à
résoudre les problèmes que j'ai pour
atteindre ce marché là et donc comme ça
on veut on a on est on est aussi aidés
subventionnés pour travailler que des
laboratoires qui vont apporter de
l'innovation de l'entreprise ont tout ça
est fait pour drainer de l'innovation
dans l'entreprise qui va gagner de la
compétitivité nous c'est arrivé un
moment où aldebaran avait envie de
tester un nouveau type de capteur en
fait un capteurs intelligents donc
depuis très longtemps on fréquentait une
entreprise qui avait développé une
caméra qui faisait du prétraitement
c'est à dire la caméra comprend déjà une
partie de ce qu'elle voit et va envoyer
en plus de l'image une partie de l'île
de l'interprétation de cette image et
puis il y avait aussi par ailleurs une
problématique scientifique qui nous
intéressait qui n'était pas éloignée de
ce que faisait cette caméra qui était de
comprendre les gestes que le robot non
seulement lui parle avec des mots mais
quand on s'exprime devant un robot ont
fait les gestes est important que rob
ruygh comprennent ces gestes parce que
va modifier parfois le sens des mots qui
comprennent aussi l'activité le
mouvement qu'on fait ce qu'on se lève et
ce qu'on boit
voilà merci je me suis bien reposé je
vais me lever
bah oui j'ai du boulot hein c'est pas
tout de rigoler ah ouais je m'assois et
je vais applaudir c'était très bien
absolument
ces innovations ont été développés dans
le projet roméo un robot humanoïde de
grande taille conçu pour les personnes
âgées
l'une de ses particularités c'est d'être
attentif au monde qu'il entonne il a des
yeux mobiles
donc il peut bouger les yeux et donc ça
ça compte beaucoup dans l'expressivité
il a quatre processeurs ce qui lui
permet d'être quatre fois plus
intelligent que ses autres copains romeo
est encore en développement
ce sont ses capacités sa faculté de
repérer les mouvements des personnes
âgées et particulièrement leur chute ce
qui a intéressé l'europe
ce projet a été financé dans le cadre du
fonds européen feder un fond aujourd'hui
gérés par la région pour la période
2014-2020 l'île de france dispose de 185
millions d'euros pour développer
l'économie
au total ce sont 5 140 millions d'euros
qui sont versées pendant six ans par
l'île de france pour le compte de
l'europe des aides pour le secteur
économique mais aussi social
l'agriculture et les initiatives
d'emplois pour les jeunes tout se fait
sur la base
d'appels à projets et la commission
européenne nous a demandé d'avoir des
critères techniques très strictes et que
l'on puisse objective et les choix que
nous avons et donc nous avons mis en
place une commission consultative des
élus de la région peu pouvoir discuter
de ces fonds là après roméo la société
aldebaran à d'autres projets avec des
financements européens pour
l'amélioration de l'acoustique de ces
robots leur apprentissage mais aussi le
développement et l'utilisation de now
pour les enfants autistes
voilà pour ce reportage de marion
lefebvre sur les robots secteur d'avenir
pour l'europe ou pas nous en parlons
avec deux invités de député européen
mady delvaux bonjour vous venez du
luxembourg l'âge et au groupe des
socialistes et démocrates européens et
vous connaissez très bien les robots à
je découvre j'ai découvert depuis que je
suis parlementaire alimentaire est à vos
côtés dominique riquet bonjour alors
vous êtes français et membre de la
commission industrie recherche et
énergie et du groupe adl spécialiste
aussi de ce secteur une question
peut-être pour vous mady delvaux
l'avenir de l'homme les robots sont ils
l'avenir de l'homme au contraire ceux
qui détruiront cet avenir je pense qu'à
l'avenir ce sera l'interaction là
combinaison le travail ensemble entre
les robots et les hommes et surtout
qu'il faudra faire bien attention que
nous puissions danser avec les robots et
non pas lutter contre les fauteurs aussi
parce que ça peut être synonyme de
menace pour l'emploi très souvent mais
quand on regarde de plus près on ne sait
jamais ce que nous apportera l'avenir
mais en regardant de plus près on voit
par exemple l'allemagne qui à
l'industrie la plus avancée en europe et
salle qui utilise le plus de robots on
voit que si on utilise intelligemment le
robot il nous apporte un surplus de
toute façon nous voyons que les remous
tous les piles et continent sont en
train de développer des programmes de
robots de robotique et moi je pense que
les robes ou seront là ils sont là ils
seront là et donc il vaut mieux qu'on
s'y intéresse et qu'on s'y investissent
veuille écrit qu'est ce que ça vous
plairait d'être réveillé par now peppers
romeo je pense que sous le vocable de
robots et des choses extraordinaires
mans différente on a vu un robot de
services humanoïdes mais il ya des
robots qui sont dans par ap la gestion
des logiciels de trading dans les
banques il ya des robots qui sont dans
les usines et qui ont un aspect
différent
je pense que il faut pas se reporter
seulement à l'image du date du rebond
tchèque des années trente du mot robot
c'est tout les secteurs d'activité qui
peuvent placer un exemple de leurs
d'innovation moi je pense que c'est
mieux que rien
est ce que ça peut être important
d'emplois c'est ça ma question on sait
que ça ça a été démontrée samantha
productivité la compétitivité ça
augmente l'emploi qualifié mais ça
détruit oui dans l'emploi mon qualifie
donc ça détruit quand même des emplois
donc
on a des avis souvent divergents il est
sûr qu'il y aura les emplois qualifiés
on en aura toujours besoin les enfants
les emplois non qualifiés ils seront
bizarrement moins touché par la
robotique mais ce sens surtout les
travaux qui auront une certaine routine
qui sont au milieu que les regroupent
pourrait facilement faire donc il ne
faut pas se leurrer il y aura des
gagnants et des perdants et si nous
voulons rester compétitif je pense qu'il
faut investir aussi dans un petit alors
est ce que c'est votre avis que vous
pensez que l'europe est encore dans la
course ou qu'elle est déjà dépassée par
d'autres d'autres en plus l'europe est
un leader dans la robotique puisqu'elle
représente que plus du tiers du marché
de l'art gothique elle le restera
non seulement elle le restera mais grâce
on l'a vu d'ailleurs un certain nombre
de dispositifs européens
d'abord il ya un dispositif qui
s'appelle se pacsent et qui est à
appuyer sur la non reprise conjointe va
mobiliser plusieurs milliards d'euros
sur la recherche c'est ce qu'on a vu
avec des eaux
alors oui c'est un leader et en même
temps c'est quoi qu'il arrive à ce
qu'ils aient assez d'argent pour ce
secteur là bon de toute façon il n'ya
jamais assez d'argent encore pour tous
mais bon il ya quand même des flagships
donc un des objectifs principaux
notamment aussi du programme horizon 20
20 et ce parc est un donc un persona ria
public privé où il ya beaucoup d'argent
qui est mobilisé plus de 2 milliards sur
sur cinq ans sans parler des programmes
fédérer autres wind qu'on a quand même
reconnu qu' il faut investir puisque
c'est une partie c'est pas tout la
robotique à tous mais c'est un élément
important justement vous parlez du feder
bien justement l'un des robots qu'on
avait vus a pu être être créé grâce à
des fonds européens notamment ceux du
feder le fonds européen de développement
régional qui est allé précisément la
région ile de france
écoutez le ro blindé représentant la
région ile-de-france qui nous explique
comment comment marche c'est pour
écouter
nous souhaitons accompagner un certain
nombre de secteurs et des entreprises
dans la recherche et l'innovation
surtout dans le secteur numérique donc
c'est l'ensemble de ces de ces aspects
là qui est qui et qui est envisagée ça
peut paraître très théorique en réalité
c'est simplement par exemple delà de la
rénovation thermique sur des bâtiments
qu'est ce qu'il ya très concrètement des
zones et des conséquences pour les
habitants de
de ces logements ça peut être de là puis
à de développement de start up ça peut
être la création de pépinières
d'entreprises avec un appui aux
créateurs donc ce sont des choses qui au
bout du bout sont très très concrète à
dos les criques et les entreprises qu'on
a interrogés pour préparer ce reportage
nous ont dit que ce n'était pas
forcément facile de faire une demande de
fonds européens parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de paperasse qu'il fallait
souvent avancé les fonds être on est
déjà sûr d'être remboursé
est ce que c'est vrai je confirme c'est
vrai c'est à la fois compliqué de monter
les dossiers de les faire recevoir et
des fois compliqué dans les chapelles
dissuader ça peut dissuader certaines
s'appelait ça dissuade à la question
actuellement je pense qu'à travail qui a
été initialisé depuis quelques années
par la commission parlement ça intéresse
beaucoup pas ça pour simplifier et pour
permettre d'avoir une accessibilité plus
grand mais hamdi problème aussi s'il
faut pas non plus que les fonds publics
ne soient pas contrôlés
oui donc il faut trouver un équilibre
qui servent aux bonnes choses
s'annoncent bien fléché un équilibre
entre c'est opportun s'est bien dépensé
pour ce qu'on a dit il n'y a pas de
problème d'égarement des fonds quarante
ans est accessible et simple et ça ne
met pas en péril des entreprises si
compliqué on fait des progrès est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres tekki ceux qui ont
plus de facilité à accéder à ces fonds
non non je parle pour un problème
général mais on voit enfin ce qui me
tracasse un peu ce que l'on voit qu'il
ya certains pays où certaines régions de
pays qui sont très en pointe sur les
dossiers et il faudrait qu'on arrive à
créer des réseaux pour que des régions
qui sont moins impliquées puissent aussi
profiter les citer des exemples de ces
régions va les régions par exemple
l'allemagne
un pays où la robotique est très avancé
le nord de l'italie
en angleterre vous avez aussi une
robotique très développé quand le
danemark de la suède mais bon d'un autre
côté il ya les pays à la périphérie
enfin la commission travaille aussi sur
l'installation d'un réseautage des
centres d'excellence où on peut
s'inspirer et s'enrichit réciproquement
parce qu'en fait c'est l'industrie
européenne que nous voulons oui que nous
voulons faire avancer
alors justement vous nous dites les
robots c'est bien mais ils doivent
servir d'abord à l'industrie c'est ça
que je pense que les robots alertant
maintenant dante marc sourice vous vous
retrouvez dans la santé c'est très
important de revoir dans les services
aux personnes avec neo
vous avez retrouvé dans l'industrie mais
aussi beaucoup dans les services la
banque étant en réalité actuellement
sous des formes diverses
la robotique touche tous les secteurs et
de la vie et d'activité et donc c'est ça
a peu qui va nous réserver des surprises
parce que l'émergence de cette robotique
civile parce que vous avez aussi de
robotique militaire que cette robotique
l'un probablement va avoir des émergents
vont accepter on n'attend pas toujours
vous dites que l'europe est à la pointe
et pourtant de l'entreprise qu'on a
qu'on a chez qui on a été faire notre
reportage été racheté par des japonais
parce que c'est un problème le problème
parce que nous sommes très bons en
recherche sur l'innovation et la musique
à paris par d'autres pays la mise sur le
marché
ne sont pas des champions je pensais
aussi j et c'est là qu'il faut c'est sûr
ça qu'ils veulent qu'il faut travailler
davantage type de structuration ceci est
très capitalisation et des concurrents
dangereux dans des régimes très
différent qu'ils soient chinois rate en
direct et public où les américains et
les japonais nous espionner aussi
peut-être pour avoir accès oui c'est une
pratique qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
alors pour que ce soit que ça reste dans
le giron européen a je pense qu'il faut
s'occuper de financement des entreprises
et créer des justement des chaînes
absolument lui être maître d'oeuvre si
je puis dire la commission européenne
les états partenariat en train dé grands
et les petits
il faut changer l'écosystème il faut
aussi favoriser l'émergence de champions
européens parce que qui a racheté
aldebaran là en l'occurrence c'est le
leader japonais qui est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement changer de logiciel repère
la manière dont on traite des tags sur
les grands qui peuvent s'associer avec
des petits et pour ça il faut des
champions européens
il faut pas se faire manger par les
champions mondiaux qui sont à des
échelles mondiale leur coeur d'europe on
va souvent à voir terreau de pm
extraordinaire de recherche
extraordinaire est comme ça émergent
malgré tout l'été les fêtes pardo qui se
marie il faudra aussi créer un cadre
législatif et réglementaire qui permet
justement que les robots puissent sortir
de niveau de la recherche est entré
davantage et c'est pour ça que nous
avons un groupe de travail dans la
commission juridique justement est
justement votre mission c'est une
delvaux de la mission volution et bien
merci à vous de nous avoir apporté cet
éclairage sur ces petits robots qui
symbolise l'innovation en europe c'est
la fin de cette émission je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine à
bruxelles ce sera alors à hamadi qui
sera aux commandes de l'émission très
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf bail
bon